[Musik]
schweizer in los angeles präsentiert das
stück heimat egal wo sie sind
[Musik]
hat er wieder weg
da sein
[Musik]
architekt orange ist immer auf der suche
nach guten plänen
er hat gerade einen überraschenden anruf
bekommen ein junger bauunternehmer
braucht sein know how
er ist sport so ein schnitt und
schweizer zieht so ergeben genau bis zum
2 es ist jetzt zwar vor zwei und dann
[Musik]
sagt mir was auch immer du hier machen
willst oder muss ist das nicht kalt den
shorts ich friere mir den arsch ab freut
mich ich bin bauunternehmer und wurde
vom neuen besitzer beauftragt wir machen
hier größere arbeiten küchen bäder
wir machen das haus nummer 25 und das
tool häuschen
du hast uns also häufig sehen
[Musik]
wie lange brauchst du für die pläne ich
weiß nicht schaffst du es bis donnerstag
ich versuche es kann aber nichts
versprechen
wenn du alles aus mist und die fotos bis
montag machen kannst
ich mag es bis heute abend das ist nun
möglich
ich krieg das ziemlich schnell hin sie
sind das haus hat oben einen konnten
haus sie haben es aufgegeben wegen der
bewilligung und auch wegen finanzieller
schwierigkeiten mit dem eigentümer
vielleicht sollte ich mit einem meiner
investoren darüber reden
das einzige was bleibt sind die oberen
schränke die streichen wir und der rest
kommt raus drei zimmer bleiben wie sie
sind
ein badezimmer fällt hier die
hauptarbeit an
ja das meist ist hier nötig schick mir
das zuerst und dann legen wir los
genial super ich mach mich an die arbeit
ich schick dir eine zeichnung okay
[Musik]
sind einen plan relativ einfach zu
machen ob es stufen und so ein stück ist
maschinen nicht machbar weil ein muss
mir jetzt eine sache liefern und rx doch
immer dass bis morgen liefern
und ich habe mir das nicht länger bis
man muss ich mit leine die haut und ich
weiß dass ich nichts und lieferung
connections aber connection mit dem mini
jobs schafft keinerlei kita besuchen
auch witze größtes projekt die arme zu
heben ist offen aber im endeffekt hätte
er viel gute connections equity
connections und den castros erwachsen
[Musik]
nach wochenlangem renovieren aufpolieren
und reparieren die gretchenfrage werden
die käufer sich die klinke in die hand
geben
[Musik]
woran ist hier erfreut und donna doria
und mein mann pascual cebit und der name
deiner schwester die sängerin
wir wohnten 15 jahre in diesem haus
jetzt kehren wir in die heimat zurück
deshalb verkaufen sie das haus dazu ja
weil wir hier keine familie haben gute
entscheidung
schauen sie sich das haus doch an den
kindern gefällt ist wir suchen genauso
ein haus vor allem weil die kinder raus
können den ganzen tag drinnen auch in
der schule ist nicht ideal
stimmt und hier ist es hier sicher und
ruhig kommen sie rein
wir lassen sie das haus an ein gesicht
ich habe noch nie so viele leute bei
einer besichtigung gesehen
um zu verhindern dass die hunde die
interessenten vertreiben taucht das paar
bei einer freundin unter
[Musik]
schnapsidee oder weiser entschluss neu
anlegt prüfung um prüfung ab wir sind
hier beim department of motor vehicles
ich mache jetzt die schriftliche prüfung
für meinen führerschein seit vier jahren
versuche ich den fahrer ausweisen der
schweizer zu machen und des verkehrs
konnte unterricht und nothelfer kurs
habe ich besucht und die theorieprüfung
zweimal gemacht weil ich wiederholen
musste ich habe etwa 25 fahrstunden
genommen und gut 2000 franken investiert
ich bin sicher zu perfektionistisch
ich sage mir noch fahre ich nicht
perfekt also warte ich noch zu mit der
es ist heuer und ich hatte nicht mehr
viel geld und hier kostet es alles in
allem 36 dollar
wenn ich durch falle kostet es sechs
franken fürs wiederholen und ich könnte
schon am nächsten tag wieder antreten
das ist hier viel einfacher denn es sind
automatik auto
außerdem kann ich den schein ganz
einfach in der schweiz umschreiben
lassen deshalb ist das ein guter plan
ich bin unter druck
ich habe gegen mitternacht mit dem
lernen begonnen und durchgemacht bis
vier das bis vor fünf minuten
ich rechne mit einer stunde schlange
stehen und einer stunde prüfung
ich hoffe es wird gut gehen denn es sind
viele rechtliche fragen zum beispiel die
höhe der frau diese bei fahrzeug
versicherungen oder die höchstmögliche
buße daumen drücken und hoffen dass es
klappt
[Musik]
geht das so hierunter entschuldigung
du kannst meine brüste anfasst ich
begrapschte sie so groß sind sie eher
nicht du kannst die berührung gut
vermeiden
francesca und ihre freundinnen basteln
weiter an ihrem liebesleben ihr buntes
ausstellungsprojekt nimmt form an
wir sind alles frauen die in los angeles
leben aber wir sind auch alle mütter und
vor allem künstlerinnen es kochte ein
thema und die liebe die liebe zur kunst
die nächstenliebe die liebe zur stadt
das ist spannend ich arbeite sehr oft
allein aber die idee zusammen
auszustellen kam ganz natürlich der
solidaritätsgedanke ist sehr stark und
die lust sich gegenseitig zu helfen sich
aneinander zu reiben das haben wir
schnell aufgegriffen und das ist super
da ist der braucht nabel unter würde arm
auf wir haben den ganzen tag gebraucht
um zuerst verschiedene charaktere und
dann daraus ein kleines fanmagazin zu
machen das ist der tag an dem wir etwas
kollaboratives machen aus dem vielleicht
ein etwas wird man sehen
[Musik]
wie viel platz du hast entweder bist du
ein bisschen tiefer unsere künstlerische
praxis beruht tatsächlich auf liebe die
heftig sein kann leidenschaftlich die
nicht zwingend leicht oder sanft sein wo
das stürmisch sein wie wenn du verlierst
zum leidenschaftlich
wir sind alle multidimensional sowie
frauen und die liebe nun mal sind ist
eine knallharte statt
es ist hart hier zu bleiben hier zu
leben die leute sind hier um zu arbeiten
um geld zu machen um erfolgreich zu sein
muss wenn eine dich grüßt denk dir
sofort daran was für ihn herausspringen
könnte
das ist anstrengend du machst die füße
mit den beinen an dem teil hast du nicht
gearbeitet machen füße los jetzt machen
füßen
welchen teil hast du noch nicht gemacht
den er doch den da habe ich gemacht
1 23
[Musik]
don pasquale haben unterschlupf gefunden
bei ihrer alten freundin betty hallo
partie das ist lustig ich kaufe dir
einen heidenspaß
vielleicht mache ich ein anderes muster
ich habe ein haus nur für hunde an
diesem haus ist für sie die sie zwei
türen dieses fenster so partie gehen wie
er wenn wir aus dem haus müssen also ist
auf unserem hügel brannte sind wir zu
passiv
wir haben hier einige nächte verbracht
wir vor dir zurück konnten und heute
sind wir hier wegen der hausbesichtigung
partie und eine andere freundin gehörten
zu den chip sieht einer professionellen
tanztruppe die in filmen und am broadway
auftrag eines tages hat patti gesagt
dura braucht ein macht sie hatten ronny
wo arrangiert und so haben wir uns
kennengelernt und kurz darauf hat mir
durch ein heiratsantrag gemacht
natürlich glauben wir den letzten teil
wenn du glauben will dass ich um deine
hand angehalten habe dann ist es okay
damals war sie sehr zurückhaltend und
ruhig
später hat sich die kontrolle übernommen
da war es vorbei du bist du ich hasse es
dich gehen zu lassen das ist mein
problem
dann kommen uns doch in der schweiz
besuchen ja ich konnte schreiben uns
mails und sms
[Musik]
ich habe gerade zwei stunden prüfungen
hinter mir und ich bestanden
ich bin glücklich wir mussten lange
warten ich musste tausende visa zeigen
tausende dokumente vorliegen da ich ja
keine amerikanerin bin aber die prüfung
war super kurz der nächste schritt
besteht darin einen fahrlehrer zu finden
falls ich keinen amerikaner finden der
bereit ist gratis mit mir herum zu
fahren
[Musik]
auf wiedersehen partie wir sehen uns
bald wieder
es wird zeit heimzukehren
der nachmittag geht zu ende die
besichtigungen sind vorbei
sie warten bis monica grünes licht gibt
wir sind auf dem rückweg gute
nachrichten
sie hat angebote die leicht über dem
festgesetzten preis legen
es gab leute die gekommen sind und
gesagt haben sie würden mehr bieten
jetzt können sie gegeneinander bieten
sie hat wirklich getan was sie
versprochen
los angeles ein abbild der welt
ein wahrhaft buntes ethnisches mosaik
klassen und rassen treffen zwar
aufeinander verbrüdern sich aber nicht
eine regenbogen gesellschaft von
afro-amerikanern chicanos und asiaten
man reist um die welt und verlässt doch
nie die agglomeration muslime fahren
hier nicht auf was haben gegenwärtigen
politischen klima liegt doch alle
religionen konnten ihre gotteshäuser
errichten
er lässt auch die drittgrößte jüdische
stadt der welt nach tel aviv und new
york
zwei schritte von der synagoge entfernt
liegt dieses nichts unkeuscheres thora
es gibt würste bemerkenswert wir sind an
einer versammlung der swiss mixa wir
machen diese treffen um andere schweizer
kennenzulernen die in los angeles leben
um freundschaften zu schließen zu helfen
wenn jemand etwas braucht
ich kann nicht jeden monat dabei sein
das erlaubt mein job nicht oft muss ich
arbeiten wenn sie sich treffen
manchmal fehlt mir die schweiz
wir alle haben so ein gefühl von heimweh
deshalb organisieren wir diese treffen
damit wir uns der schweiz näher fühlen
dank des essens dank der freunde
[Musik]
pacific palisades im westen der stadt in
diesem wohnviertel kamen die deutschen
unter die vor den nazis geflohen sind
wie literatur nobelpreisträger thomas
mann
das viertel das in den 1920 er jahren
von methodisten gegründet wurde hat sich
komplett verändert die bungalows von
damals sind luxusvillen gewichen
[Musik]
das haus gebaut wurde und vor zehn
jahren hat mit zentren das ist ganz
dunkel sie also kein innerer und dann
haben wir das komplette umbau aber
schlechter charakter vom mit centerview
spalter mit center sind entstand das
50er 60er jahre als low budget user sind
experimentalphysik sie das heißt viele
offene space viel glas und ganz einfache
konstruktion und ganz gleich eingebaut
wurde 60er jahre
da ist überholen hat so als ein paar
zahlen erklärt und die hat man auch
wünschten müsse halte wenn jemand hat
ein spieler der in pacific palisades
zwick weg sie ist von hotspots
mannschaft sollte sich eigentlich genau
das umgekehrte sollte sich der sehr
exklusiv im interview so sind sie vor
vier jahren
kunzes unter tag auf den herren ein
tunnel baut das man von einem haus in
sande houska vw-gesetz da oben ist es so
dass du den charakter von quartieren mit
deutsch vor ende august muss es im bus
und zwei user wert
das wort stadt mesa wurde auch das hat
der anderen jahre braucht bis mir
überhaupt beiden vorher immer finden
immer irgendwie lösung man muss einfach
mit der stadt spielen anstatt tunnel
heimsten am schluss segment obwohl es
ist ein irrtum
[Musik]
die idee ist dass man nicht weiß dass
das engagement in turin ist der schweiz
studiert wollte gar als störrisch oder
womit eine fahrt mit dem auto und das
ist ja eine csi es ist heikel denn man
muss mit den fahrzeugen rein und raus
der raum soll funktionieren aber nicht
riechen wo sie wusste was geht und was
nicht und wie man dieses mit century
haus zu etwas modernen um das kann nur
einer in einem einfamilienhaus hast nur
anrecht auf eine küche die distanz
zwischen hier und dort so groß ist
wollten wir hier eine kleine küche
machen aber das ist nicht erlaubt also
mussten wir tricksen und haben behauptet
dass dies eine koschere küche ist was
erlaubt ist
du kannst eine normale küche und eine
koschere küche in einem einfamilienhaus
haben aber nicht zwei gleiche und sie
haben nicht nachgefragt
sie wollten nichts wissen sie fragen
nicht ob du jude oder moslem bist
[Musik]
ja wir gehen raus werden doron pascual
mit leichtem herzen und vollen taschen
in die schweiz zurückkehren
die stunde der wahrheit hallo wie geht's
[Musik]
wie fühlst du dich heute morgen beruhige
dich sagt mit wie vielen angeboten
rechnest du das ist nicht die anzahl die
wir erhalten haben
wir haben elf angebote bekommen ab 520
und 24 550 2 für 550 zwei top angebote
das ist fantastisch
das kannst du laut sagen ich bin davon
ausgegangen dass es viel mehr angebote
zum basispreis geben würde
davor hatte ich am meisten angst damit
habe ich nicht gerechnet
das ist typisch für leute die ihr haus
verkaufen wollen
sie glaubten wenn du einen höheren preis
verlangt findest du keine käufer oder du
musst verhandeln und ihn nach unten
korrigieren
sie kann das nicht verstehen weil es
nicht ihr beruf ist sie unterrichtet
ballett das können wir nicht begreifen
für toni aber und in diesem fall hat sie
mir vertraut ich will etwas besorgt weil
ich sehe wie der markt in vielen
vierteln einbricht darum habe ich mir
nicht alles gesagt
ich wollte nicht dass sie in panik
ausbricht das ist mein job und ich
wollte die zielsetzung erreichen ihren
preis sie ist meine lieblingsstadt
lehrerin
überhaupt ist sie mir die liebste
mein leben sie hat mir meinen körper
gegeben weil sie nicht trainiert hat
danke sie ist ein vorbild für mich so
hart zu arbeiten in ihrem alter
alle ihre schülerinnen und schüler
lieben sie über alles nicht nur ich bin
glücklich dass ich ihr helfen kann
mein ziel war es ihr freude zu bereiten
mein bestes zu geben um ihr das
zurückzugeben was sie für mich getan hat
[Musik]
du sprichst richtig gut weniger
du kannst spielen kommen wann immer du
willst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ob als stürmer oder verteidiger meine
leidenschaft für football geht auf das
jahr 1983 zurück als wir in lugano
lugano silges gegründet haben
ich habe mich sofort in diesen sport
verliebt und immer davon geträumt in
amerika zu spielen fast von anfang an
habe ich hier bei den kaliforniern
bandits gespielt nach den 90er jahren
wir haben dreimal die nationalen
meisterschaften gewonnen
ich bin einer der schweizer spieler die
in den staaten professionell football
gespielt haben
vor zwei jahren wurde ich in die hall of
fame aufgenommen
das war das größte überhaupt für mich
eine riesige anerkennung und die mich
sehr glücklich gemacht hat in der
ruhmeshalle als bester spieler der
geschichte geehrt zu werden das ist
fantastisch das hat mich sehr gefreut
als football spieler muss ich mich
schützen
in meinem alter ich versuche meine knie
zu schützen und fesseln die ellenbogen
als leitantrag ich handschuhe schulter
schoner und natürlich ein helm
die meisten der spieler sind zwischen 20
und 30 jahre alt
ich bin 54 und damit der älteste aktive
spieler kalifornien
[Musik]
das ist für dich
danke
im sportler paradies sind alle fußballer
willkommen das stärkt den teamgeist und
nur der zählt hier die horen die kinder
vom nachwuchstraining es ist ihr letztes
training wir wollten tristans
fußballtrainer sehen der weg geht
wir wurden eingeladen und sind gekommen
es ist eine internationale schule die
sich an den französischen und
amerikanischen er plan hält
im französischen wird mehr geschichte
unterrichtet als im amerikanischen sie
sollen eine breite allgemeinbildung
bekommen das war sehr gut ich mag den
lehrer es sehr mit
ich bringe die kinder zur schule fahre
zu meinem atelier und stelle den wecker
der klingelton
ich hole die kinder wieder ab fahre nach
hause mache das essen
[Musik]
heute spielen wir fußball
anja hat das vorgeschlagen leider weiß
ich nicht ob ich nicht besser hätte
absagen sollen
ich tendiere dazu super motiviert und
super aufgedreht zu sein wenn man mir
etwas vorschlägt sofort so sagen ohne zu
überlegen
aber dann habe ich realisiert dass sich
am morgen noch eine prüfung habe und
normalerweise nie fußballspiele
ich glaube ich habe das letzte mal mit
14 fußball gespielt und zwar nicht
freiwillig während der obligatorischen
schulzeit ist nicht ganz wohl dabei
ich hätte besser vorschlagen sollen ins
kino oder ins restaurant zu gehen
wie geht's gut und er dafür der unteren
vorstellen ein freund so erfolg im kino
oder im ausgang hätten l'oreal und ihre
freundin anja diese begegnung sicher nie
gehabt
darf ich sie bitten ein foto von uns zu
machen del piero ist super bekannt wir
haben alessandro del piero
er ist sehr berühmt gewesen vor ein paar
jahren das war kugel
viele meiner freunde sind fußballfans
das wird sie rasend machen wenn ich
ihnen das foto schicke auch anja spielt
fußball
als verteidigerin in einem genfer klub
tut gut nach dem unterricht den kopf
frei zu kriegen weil gerade prüfungszeit
ist konnten nicht viele kommen deshalb
sind wir so wenige ich setze mich voll
ein weil ich gewinnen will mit krankheit
ich befürchte aber dass ich mit den
füßen nicht gut genug
ich glaube basketball wäre besser für
mich gut ich kann mich austoben wenn du
den ganzen tag in der bibliothek ist um
zu lernen tut das richtig gut
[Musik]
geht es gut mir ja brauchst du das für
morgen für montag und verstehst du es
oder nicht es geht
ich muss noch die rückseite machen und
dass er auch noch kalkulieren und hast
du das hier gemacht noch nicht ich
wollte dass zuerst machen weil das
leichter
wie geht es deinem handgelenk danke dass
du mir das alles gezeigt hast du schuft
ist richtig
ich kenne nicht viele klischees über die
schweizer aber ich weiß dass sie sehr
genau sehen immer pünktlich und jedes
mal wenn ich mir mal bitte etwas für
mich zu machen
dann macht sie es auch bei meinem vater
hingegen ist das nicht immer garantiert
manchmal vergisst er es meine mutter
hingegen denkt immer an alles die
meisten meiner freunde haben keine
künstler als eltern mama und papa haben
mir geholfen meine leidenschaft für die
musik zu entdecken und es ist toll dass
sie mich unterstützen bei allem was mir
spaß macht
meine eltern ich mag was ihnen gefällt
aber ich verhalte mich nicht wie sie
meine persönlichkeit ist nicht so wie
ihre sie sind recht streng wenn es um
meine noten und die schule geht aber bei
anderen dingen er nicht auch bei der
zeit die ich vor dem bildschirm
verbringen sind sie streng aber das ist
okay
hast du die hausaufgaben gemacht weil
hier liegen laut der sorgen auf dem
boden
ich habe einen bucheinband gemacht sie
für ein buch ein band für wti für das
buch das ich mit meinen freunden gemacht
habe 101 arten ein hotdog wettessen zu
gewinnen und sie schön ich mag es wenn
du witzige sachen machst das ist super
in zehn jahren sehe ich mich mit einer
musikausbildung irgendwo in der
musikbranche
[Musik]
nl wird es früh nacht aber man arbeitet
bis spät du versprichst mir was und
machst es dann nicht deshalb rufe dich
an
was ist los bei hin so nett und fangen
aber beweg deinen hintern
auch ich muss sachen machen auf die ich
keine lust habe das gehört nun mal zum
leben
wenn dir ein amerikaner keine richtige
antwort geben kann ruft dich niemals an
und sagt ich weiß es nicht
er ruft dich einfach nicht an er hätte
mich heute morgen um acht uhr anrufen
sollen und hat es nicht gemacht
ich weiß nicht wie viele nachrichten ich
ihm hinterlassen habe
er ruft mich einfach nicht zurück weil
er keine antwort wenn du bis freitag
nicht fertig bist voll richtig und
stelle jemand anderes ein und du kommst
für die zusatzkosten auf mach es endlich
aber so funktioniert das nicht
nein das stimmt nicht für einige
funktioniert das doch die deg profis kai
fertig bullshit viel geduld bis man
einfach geduld platzt und der regierung
mein termin in der nehmen so ein
friedlicher mensch aber ein ich bin
diesem fall ist
hoeneß mit weniger projektron internet
letzten zehn jahren fünf bis zehn jahren
ist extrem turbulent los angeles die
mieten ist in einer stadt zu zahlen
dafür muss man habe schon im auto sitze
zwischen sport und habe den will ihn
erstaunt hat zum heiraten will in zehn
minuten der heißen und nicht selten los
angeles organisiert ein glücksfall
schöne ausblicke
[Musik]
endlich betritt wenn die arena
der älteste der erfahrenste ein star
wenn die ernten bewundernde blicke von
den spielern den coach den kommentator
und dem publikum
[Musik]
es ist das beste spiel der welt mann
gegen mann
gladiatoren das wurde früher in einer
römischen arena gespielt mit lehrern und
bären
heute wird mit kerlen wie diesen hier
gespielt älterwerden ist hart für uns an
ich verstehe nicht wie er noch all diese
dinge machen kann wenn du in seinem
alter nicht auf diesem niveau spielen
kannst dann ist das ein geschenk gottes
ich rufe das weil sie uns noch lange
erhalten bleibt auch wenn er nicht mehr
selber spielen die jungs brauchen
[Musik]
in all den jahren habe ich mir schon
alles mögliche gebrochen weil die finger
den daumen nur beide fesseln das knie
ich hatte eine durchlöcherte lunge im
moment habe ich rückenschmerzen
es ist ein gefährlicher sport
[Musik]
das ist das feld der träume land der
magie heim der stars wir haben hier
viele stars auf dem feld gesehen und der
typ da rennt ideen
mein gott vor randy ich bin sehr gerührt
weil ich weiß dass ich aufhören muss
ich bin traurig einerseits weil ich
weiterspielen möchte aber ich weiß auch
dass ich das nicht mehr kann
gleichzeitig bin ich glücklich und froh
weil ich weiß es ist dem sport verbunden
bleibe den ich mein ganzes leben lang
geliebt habe
[Musik]
es ist ein kampf mann gegen mann wie bei
den gladiatoren
so ist nicht nur dieser sport sondern
auch das leben in los angeles
angeschossen ausweichen rangeln und
loslegen und immer in bewegung bleiben
es ist gut für die seele
ich hoffe die schranke geht auch niemand
und da auch nicht betrieben sind kinder
heute ist die oscar verleihung jetzt
dürfen wir nicht mehr
[Musik]
der hatte
ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schwitzen in los angeles präsentiert
wurde von swiss stock diamond egal wo
sie sind
[Musik]